this week on quadriga liberating libya
the failed intervention this major fuel
depot was set ablaze as rival militias
fought for control of tripoli's
International Airport the fighting in
Tripoli has been going on for weeks and
has turned the south of the capital into
a battlefield the situation has been
deemed so unstable that the US has
evacuated its embassy staff and
suspended diplomatic ties Germany and
many other countries have followed suit
in the three years since the Western
intervention helped depose Libya's
former strongman muammar gaddafi the
country's fledgling leadership has not
managed to disarm the rival militias now
only days before the recently elected
parliament is set to get to work Libya
is on the verge of becoming a failed
state your host this week Elias lon
hello and welcome to a new edition of
quadriga the international community
associated and attached great hopes to
the future of Libya after the overthrow
of Moammar Gadhafi but unfortunately it
did not turn out to be that way not yet
anyway so the question is what went
wrong in Libya and perhaps more
importantly how to fix it how to bring
Libya back on the right track that's
what I want to talk about on today show
together with these three individuals
welcome to Malik a bakery is an
orthopedic surgeon from Tripoli and an
activist in defending physicians rights
and in improving the health system in
his home country libia daniel gala is
the editor-in-chief of teen eat the
german language magazine on the Middle
East Africa and the Muslim world he lost
visited Libya shortly before the
parliamentary elections in June and
Stefano casiano is a political
journalist and author he is currently
serving as a Berlin correspondent for
the Italian newspaper pagina novant
innova and has published widely on
energy policy in North Africa
gentlemen welcome to the show let's get
right to it Malik Elba Cory before we
get into the details as to what actually
went wrong in Libya you were just
recently there in june tell us what's
the situation there the situation now
olivia is very difficult there's a lot
of violence the violence is escalating
in Libya now the current situation in
the past few weeks we can say that there
is no water there is a shortage of
curiousity all gas stations specially in
Tripoli are closed and the security
situation is very difficult and sire
Tripoli and also in the other city
Benghazi yeah I think the problem seems
to be that no one is really in control
of the country isn't that the case after
the overthrow of Gaddafi they've had
five governments since 2011 and right
now the country seems to be ruled more
or less for the lack of a better term by
up to 1,700 militia groups this is right
this is this is absolutely right the
situation in Libya that the government
is very weak and they are only issuing
reports and they are advising people not
to to go to the clashing areas and the
violence areas and the situation is
ruled by militias decided situation yeah
Dinah gala moammar gadhafi strong men of
Libya ruled the country since 1969 you
ruled the country for 42 years now isn't
a normal one would argue that there is
no tradition and no understanding of
democracy in Libya well if it was only
for the democracy you know I think we
could cook the situation the problem
here is there is no understanding of a
state and Libyans say that you know
candidly Gaddafi's rule was kind of
replacing state like structures and what
we have now in Libya is that people have
no respect for for for for the
institutions of the state if they are
there which I find quite fascinating too
because like you know the the great the
great magic of Libya on the other hand
is that people due to a very intact and
good social fabric and good social
structures they managed they managed to
live in this country and they managed to
maintain a certain kind of you know
order and security without in the total
absence of a state so I don't think for
me as an as an Orientalist and somebody
who's like studying the Middle East it
was it was fascinating to see how people
got on and they managed and you know
even they they they they took care of
their own security but of course like in
the last couple of months due to a very
few very structural failures and
mistakes the situation escalated and we
see also how vulnerable this this
absence of a state can be as I said five
government since 2011 the country still
has no Constitution you were in Libya
shortly before the parliamentary
elections in June they were held yet
they didn't bring any stability at the
outcome of this government this election
no the last election was neglected by
the Libyans themselves because they said
we don't know the people we are waiting
for the Libyans were very frustrated and
and disappointed of the performance of
the of the Parliamentary Assembly which
was there before the National Congress
and they saw that you know the election
doesn't bring democracy and election
doesn't bring freedom and that not only
a government but also some kind of a
National Congress can behave like a
dictator because it can kind of you know
disenfranchised the people and it can
take all the power and in the end not
you know well managed this power so i
think the elections are not not the
issue here on the other hand this is
another paradox of libya the
Constitutional Assembly is working
quietly and very efficiently they are
very professional people there are
people that take their work very
seriously so you know on the one hand
you have good news coming out of Libya
you have a high level of you know saved
self-sustainability and you know
engagement and a lot of Libyans coming
from the American from America from
Europe from abroad to you know invest in
their country and and and and and
they're ready to assume responsibility
this is the paradox on the one hand it's
the downside but on the other hand there
is like a big potential in this country
while the potential hopefully Libya will
live up to at some point in the future
but right now sadly it seems to be
engaged in anarchy and chaos as we said
70 casiano up 2700 militia groups all of
them / ideology by region by geography
it's very hard to keep the oversight
isn't it's we must decide here try to
understand here i guess if Libya is a
failed state already or not if this
looks like Somalia or not because I will
say academically speaking this is a
typical situation in a democracy in a
state which is not fully established you
remove the dictator the normal tendency
is not the one towards democracy by the
one towards warlordism towards
Praetorian ism on top of that Libya's
got the problem of oil and gas this can
be a factor for stability in some cases
in some other cases this is a factor for
energy groups want to seize the centers
of control
for the oil reaches and then the
competition between these groups becomes
even more violent especially if you have
offshore oil rigs so in the water these
rigs that extract minerals hydrocarbons
the goal is to seize the capital if you
have oil on shore so in the territory
the goal is to assist the region in
Libya you have both so this is a big
problem for the country and you've also
already the question which I will direct
in a little while to to Moloch is Libya
already a failed state what is it is it
a failed state if we must make this
judgment basing on what we heard the
number the amount of militias and the
ability of the government to control the
territory and the status of the
infrastructure the supplies for the
population I am afraid I have to start
thinking that Libya is already a counter
in a state of anarchy malaga bikkuri i
get a sense that you don't necessarily
agree I don't think so the situation
Olivia when we think about what happened
in the last three years it's normal
what's happening now there was an
international introversion since three
years now and there was more than 20,000
airstrikes against Libyan army and
libyan defense and Gaddafi army which is
the Libyan army now I think the Libyan
people think that the international
society gave Libya and a very very rich
country in a silver plate two armed
groups and non trained armed groups also
to annex cream political groups they are
that they are now ruling Libya we have
hope that the last elections this is
actual this is our last hope that the
next gathering and the third of August
will will do something or
we'll make something in the future in
Libya but I can say that the situation
is difficult but a failed state this is
this is not the exact word what went
wrong we've talked about the potential
that Libya has a lot of educated people
in the country and after the fall of
Moammar Gadhafi a lot of people said
Libya is going to be a regional player
Libya is looking at a bright future
obviously it didn't turn out to be that
way in your view what went wrong what
went wrong since three years living
people had so much hope that we will
have a better future a very good future
for our children but this is not to what
happened malicious Libyan relations are
fighting each other now different
political groups are fighting each other
with an international intervention oh
also there is a support from neighboring
country to certain militias and the
thing here that there is a fight over
money and power in Libya now it's true
there is a fight over money and power
but there is also a mentality here which
which which looks at the at the country
or the nation as a spoil of the
revolution and every part every region
and every militia which represents
different regions is trying to to to to
get its share so you know the people in
Benghazi said we started the revolution
without us this revolution would never
have you know begun the Santana's say we
conquer Tripoli so we are the ones that
should have the spoils of this
revolution and the people from Misrata
say okay if we hadn't kept up the
resistance you know the revolution which
would have suffocated at a very early
stage so on the other hand you have the
the provinces of Libya where no
revolution ever took place because they
are you know tribal areas or you know
areas which remained loyal to gaddafi so
these people are all of a sudden are
being blamed and they're looked looked
down upon looked at down
by other people by but by those that you
know the architects of the revolution
saying you know you guys you better shut
up because you have no no no no no merit
in this revolution so you have no part
in the political process I think this is
a very important issue and to address
and this is not the fault of the
malicious alone it's also you know a
mental mentality people blame it now all
on Gaddafi they say you know Gaddafi he
divided us and he he introduced
tribalism to Libya and he did not want
us to become allies and friends and
Federalists whatsoever but i think you
know it's it's it's important to
understand that this is not only a
question of failed state or not failed
state of east and west or of militias
but also a deeply entrenched mentality
in the country i think you're right i
would say Qaddafi was not the one that
introduced three belisma to Libya he was
perceiving a couple of years before the
revolution that something was changing
so he implemented a program of
empowering Autonomy's you know that they
were called the Revolutionary Council
sort of Soviets which represent issues
of tribes and so on give them a voice in
the parliament there were some elections
and something like that it was perceived
that it was losing grip its grip on the
country just to give you an example it's
not by chance that in 2010 I guess
Gaddafi was invited Rome to give some
speeches by the Italian government and
we remember how Berlusconi tried to
introduce you to foster his relationship
with Libya it was a marketing show for
Gaddafi for his domestic purposes he was
losing the grip on the different issues
of all the groups that wanted to have a
say in the way the country was ruled
actually till now Gaddafi there's many
tribes are still supporting Gaddafi in
Libya there is two large tribes Olivia
are supporting Gaddafi like where fella
and worship on a tribe and also many
tribes in the south the other thing that
you're talking about a mentality we are
talking about what started the violence
Olivia since weeks now which started
violence in Libya is you can't think
that after the 25th for June the
election that violence started two or
three days after the elections this
violence and this problem is due to a
political purpose the Islamic groups and
the militias which are supporting
Islamic groups they lost the election
clearly they lost the election and they
started this violence to protect their
there to protect their future plans in
Libya and also you can't think that the
violence started in Tripoli between st.
Anne and some militias from Misrata
three or four militias on Misurata Zen
tan are staying in the airport since
three years why now misurata militias or
Islamic militias are
doing this at this particular time so
it's an orchestrated effort on your
heart of Islamist groups yeah yeah it's
trying to regain their influence in the
future Libya this is what's happening in
Libya now this there was a very
organized operation the name of the
operation is a lion operation this is
cat Kawara in arabic and there is a
political armored a political party
which called the the girl in Arabic
[ __ ] vertebra Libya and this is
supported by these militias so this is
what's happening here in Tripoli also in
Benghazi there's clashes between Libyan
army led by after and a psychic rube and
between an extreme militia extreme
Islamic militia which is unsur Shariah
and this is what sells for those you've
mentioned a couple of name for those who
don't know general Khalifa Haftar of
course Lisa Libyan National Army it was
a colonel unruhe Qaddafi turn against
him in the end and led to his overthrow
his main objective is to find the very
same Islamist that you mentioned so it
gets a bit confusing here perhaps to
some of the viewers Daniel gala if you
were to put it in a nutshell about what
this conflict is about the current
outbreak of violence in the day what is
it about really well I think Stefano is
right to the extent that resources and
the confer you know the struggle for
resources the struggle for control of
these resources is important here but
this is like one layer of of the
conflict I think the the clashes between
Islamist militias and let's say Islamist
parties even and and seculars is one
layer of the conflict there the clash
between self-declared Federalists who
believe you know in Independence or
autonomy of the provinces and those that
pro in a national state is one layer of
the conflict but there is a very very
important
I think aspect here which is the the the
interest of outside powers like regional
powers I'm not necessarily talking about
Europe the West I'm talking about
Olivia's neighbors I'm talking about the
Gulf Gulf states because Libya has
turned in the let's say in the narrative
of some Arab media and into something
like an end game scenario for the the
fight between Islamism and let's say the
National authoritarian military state
SVC as we witness at the moment in Egypt
so for the Muslim brother movement in
the region Libya is like kind of the
last hope at the moment because they've
been ousted from almost any country
where they want parliamentary elections
they have lost their power bases in many
Arab countries and and we see a large
influx of Muslim brothers and of
jihadists which is not the same but
sometimes can be allied from Egypt from
other Arab countries we even see a
reflux of jihadi fighters from Syria to
the east of Libya so Libya is is somehow
you know also falling victim to these
you know scenarios of you know power
struggles in the entire region but one
important thing I think Libya's Libyans
should be very careful not to see
themselves as victims of you know
geopolitics and to blame the others
because the blaming game I know Gaddafi
I know the neighbors did a lot of very
bad things to this country but Libyans
have to take it in their own hands now
and not believe that they are just you
know victims of external power struggles
this is a very dangerous situation
because when you when you victimize
yourself you you lose control completely
but I disagree with this opinion because
you cannot say that you people take your
only responsibility and you must do this
and you must do that the international
community and an international society
must support Libyans by any means by
political and military means i can say
that because since three years there is
no democratic base in libya there is no
experience democratic experience
Olivia also you cannot say to these
peoples are a mixture of political
backgrounds that you have now by your
own you must do an establish a state
this is very very difficult you can see
the situation what was the situation in
Iraq in Afghanistan and in Somalia we
will have a for example Iraq there was a
war between America and sedan and after
that America supported the Iraqi regime
for many years to come Libya is is now
standing alone against corruption
against violence against chaos and you
are asking Libyans to to establish a
state but firms eventually the Western
Western countries should have sent
troops boots on the ground in Libya and
stay there and and we notice it I cannot
say that but some sort of for example
the next parliament is gathering respond
to the together and the third or fourth
of august maybe the United Nation must
protect this gathering because there's a
Libyan people are they know that some
malicious they will not let this
Parliament gather this is for example
this is very easy to do so the campaign
to announce Moammar Gadhafi was indeed
let mostly by Great Britain and France
with the u.s. leading from behind so if
I understand you correctly you're very
disappointed you're very disappointed in
these countries that they only were
focused on the ouster of Mohammed
Gaddafi but not on the reconstruction of
the state of Libya do I understand you
clear this is right this is absolutely
art all the people Libyan people are
thinking like that that the
international society led an
intervention against Gaddafi and then
what we can say that the political they
are dealing with Libya and some sort of
a naive political I don't think I'm
sorry I'm sorry I have to interfere in
2012 you could see people rejoicing on
the streets of Libya it was consensus in
the country that you know it was right
for the Western alliance to leave not to
interfere not to engage in Libyan
politics the country was positive the
power was transferred from the MTC to
the to the National Congress everybody
was fine 2012 was it was a country with
lady was full of folk many Libyans
returned to the country there was no
question of whatever the West or the
international community guiding the
political process in Libya Libyans felt
strong enough to do this themselves then
subsequent you know a sequence of
mistakes have been made and my well in
the end by everybody you can of course
you can accuse the Americans yeah saying
like okay if you had saved Prime
Minister's they done when he was in an
existential fight with with with with
with the east with the strike oil
strikers you know that that you know
kept the oil exports down and Zidane was
engaging in a very in a very like you
know heads on struggle with these people
and then they they they export it
legally exported their own oil they made
him look like an idiot they make him
look like a fool with no power in his
hand he was not even the commander in
chief though he was the Prime Minister
of the country of course the Americans
he called the Americans at that time and
said like I need your help i need your
troops i need you to stop this this this
this tanker the morning glory affair the
Americans didn't do that because maybe
they done had lost their trust they
didn't believe in his competence or
whatever or they just didn't know what
to do so they did nothing so there were
a few a few like points where things
could have could have changed the state
authority could have maintained but but
but but I don't think you know the West
it was the West role to to to guide and
develop political process in Libya this
is not a matter of persons they done or
some other prime minister I'm talking
about this naive diplomacy there there
is more than 1,700 militias some of them
are criminals some of them are extreme
Islamic groups and you're asking
government and libyan which would watch
Libyans would they have no
experience in these in these things and
you are asking Libya Libyans to
establish a country to stood against
these Islamic well-organized Islamic
groups some of these Islamic groups like
answer Sharia and the other Islamic
groups they have a lot of experience and
they are well organized you can see an
internet and YouTube that they are
making high-quality videos of their
operations and they have a spokesman on
other things so some of them were in
Afghanistan some of them were in
Pakistan some of them were 10 years or
more in Gaddafi's prisons and they are
well organized and there's a shadow
government there are ruled by these
personal you cannot ask Libyan people
and the Libyan government to stand
against all of these things 70 70
clearly we have a difference of opinion
here Monica curry seems to think that
the Western powers should have aided
Libya after the overthrow of Gaddafi
whereas Daniela is saying well you know
at some point it was up to you what's
your take I think that the conflict
asthmatic stated started because the
Islamic groups did not accept the result
of the elections so this was that's why
this fade this period of violence
started then before after the concerted
effort on the part of Great Britain and
France to Alistair Moammar Gadhafi and
they probably thought job done we're
going back home maybe that they have
stayed then Egypt hapten happened what
I'm saying is that after the takeover of
our seas in Egypt what happened to the
Muslim Brotherhood rousted jailed killed
tortured everything possible and the
Islamists in Libya are afraid this is
going to happen to them as well exactly
so this is a fight not for power but for
survival they know that if they don't
oppose the secularists the parties and
also the party they actually won the
election by a large what a wide margin
this is what's going to happen to
so I think in terms of international
intervention of course you're right
Daniel without job done those of the
West thought job done if we look at the
reports published also by the US Army
they were saying this is a model
operation very few human expenses I
guess none short effective this worked
this is a model we have to introduce an
Obama actually nailed it so we have it
now a couple years later we found out
didn't work at all so if we have to face
reality the way it is this is a very
dangerous conflict on a regional level
because this is Erebus or postal
Islamism with spillover of ideology and
weapons and violence to all the Sahel
region the south of Libya south of north
africa and if we don't stop this all the
region is going to collapse so the
question is now do we need a new
international intervention and how and
indeed this is a very dangerous conflict
as was pointed out correctly by stefano
casiano because not only but certainly
you also due to its spillover effects
this is not only a conflict contained to
the country of Libya let's have a quick
look the violence and discord in Libya
is approaching the points at which is
internal problems could very well start
triggering significant geopolitical
crises olivia has the third largest oil
reserves in all of Africa even during
the latest violence Libyan whales have
been pumping out some 500,000 barrels a
day but global oil markets react
sensitively to any instability that
threatens supply
affairs Libya could also affect regional
stability the country could become a hub
for Islamist extremists which experts
fear could further destabilize
neighboring countries starting in Libya
looking east to full half of the
southern Mediterranean coastline is at
best unstable or embroiled in violent
conflict like in Israel or Syria illegal
immigration is also a key issue
particularly for Europe human
traffickers are already using Libya as a
hub to smuggle people and contraband to
the EU this could be compounded by a
refugee crisis should live yet to send
back into war well maligawa curry would
just saw the situation there the
spillover effects them before we get
into the geopolitical ramifications
let's talk about the humanitarian aspect
the humanitarian crisis that has sprung
out of this conflict yeah this is very
important now in the last few weeks
there is a disaster and there's a huge
problem inside the capital Tripoli
actually there is more than two and a
half million people in Tripoli there is
a no electricity there is no water the
old gas stations are closed also in
hospitals the situation is very very
difficult more than 3,000 nurses from
the medical staff from Philippines are
evacuated from Libya which is more than
seventy percent of new medical and
nursing personnel in in hospitals in
Libya also there is a shortage of
doctors in Libyan hospitals and this is
very difficult very difficult more than
27,000 Libyan people fleet in the last
two or three days from the Libyan
Tunisian borders there are some used
that saying that the Libyan Tunisian
borders are closed and the situation is
very difficult also from
the security side there's a lot of
kidnapping there is a political activist
and blogger which is mr. Ben moon who
was kidnapped since one week and no one
knows where he is now also there is a
lot of assassinations we can say that in
the last five or six months more than
400 350 to 400 are assassinated in
Benghazi and Tripoli until now every day
there's assassinations are going on you
know but this is this is exactly the
reason why I strongly disagree with your
narrative that the violence or in an
orchestrated manner had just started
just after the election it's gradual we
see we are we have we have achieved a
different stage of escalation now but
but this crude violence targeted
assassinations and so on started long
ago in it and it increased and increased
to a tour to a terrible extent if you
look look back like one year one and a
half years ago assassinations wear
something you know and killing was
something that happened if we consider
the fact that there are so many weapons
and so many militias in Libya rather not
very frequently because you know people
were afraid if you if there is a price
you pay for killing somebody from the
opposing militia but these targeted
assassinations is something that ink
that that you know we witness think
increasingly in the last couple of
months and I think you know the the the
current state of escalation is not only
due to the to the loss of the election I
think it it you know actually there's a
decay in manas old I I disagree this
these political assassinations are an
extension to to the current violence
here in Tripoli and Benghazi when you
see that more than 600 personnel were
assassinated from the Libyan army yeah
yeah all the assassinations most of them
are from the Libyan army and national
political activists like mrs. budahas
which were she was a political and
activist and human rights lawyer she was
a senator
one months ago I think and these
assassinations are an extension for this
violence this is a political
assassinations and many Libyan people
blame the extremist Islamist Islamic
groups for these assassinations despite
all these horrific news coming out of
Libya these days Malik what gives you
hope actually always for actual uture of
your countries the situation is horrific
as you say it but our last hope is the
next gathering of Daniel Parliament and
the fort of August also we have hope
that some third powerful third party
will intervene and who would you like to
intervene that we can say that
international society the United Nations
Libya is established and by and nineteen
nineteen hundred and fifty one
established by the United Nation so we
hope that the United Nations will
support Libyan people save Annika's our
town or do you think that scenario will
play out as holt I agree with your
pessimism sorry to say I am I'm not
confident about the fact that you want
might intervene but too busy at the
moment they should intervene in Syria
Gaza in Ukraine in Libya and soon they
happen to win also somewhere else yes
scenario then is Libya gonna fall apart
this is it I can quote some sources by
the Italian intelligence that have been
reported in the last weeks you know that
Libya supplies ten percent of the
Italian natural gas plus there is a huge
presence of
Italian our energy companies in was in
Libya they claim that in six months we
have to find alternate supply sources
because the situation is not going to be
in control under control anymore the
main italian oil company en i have
acquitted the non-essential personnel
from the onshore facilities they are now
on the offshore platforms in front of
Libya the Italian ambassador is still in
Tripoli because there is 800 Italian
expats in the capital so he wants to
stay there but they're ready to leave so
what experts in Italy say is that the
situation is not recoverable of course
you normally trust the intelligence not
for scenarios mode for facts for at
least Italian intelligence in this case
people are starting to believe in it
tanikella if the indication if the
behavior on the part of diplomatic
personnel foreign diplomatic personnel
is any indication it indeed doesn't look
very good because it's not just the
Italians the Germans have recalled their
their personnel the French the Brits
American soup the Americans anyway they
of course have a very traumatic
experience with Benghazi when ambassador
Christopher Stevens was killed do you
have any words of hope for for the
nation of Libya do you think that things
or will things get worse over they get
questions what do you hope for do you
hope for the you know to prevent the
disintegration of the country Livia to
be split off I don't think this would be
the end of the world I don't think it's
wise to do so for such a small country
with such tremendous resources but this
could happen what could temporarily I
like well you know Libya can can can
explode into many pieces but I think the
most the most let's say logical scenario
would be a division between east and
west which has you know some historical
we put you know it exists some
historical examples but that's not the
problem okay so this is absolutely not
going to happen why because there is a
mixtures of tribes and families and a
strong relations
between east and west you cannot imagine
that that many tribes are split between
West and East there is a family of
relations between West and East and I
don't think it's going to happen in the
near future but you talk about
allegiances to try that what are the
weather sends common sense of national
identity which usually keeps people
together the common sense of flashing
identity it's there but many people are
having loyalty to their tribes more than
to the country unfortunately the other
thing that you are see you are talking
about international intervention and
it's not going to happen in the near
future there is a moral responsibility
from the national international society
from America from Europe toward Libya
and the other thing that the problem
Olivia will affect the whole region you
can imagine if the Islamist Islamic
groups ruled Libya Libya is a very rich
country this will affect the whole
region and also other countries these
Islamic parties will support terrorism
all over the world Libya is not like
Afghanistan or Somalia Libya is a very
rich country when these Islamic groups
have money this will be a very big
problem to the whole region you can't
imagine what what's happening now in
mali mali this is a country as a very
poor country and there is a big problem
in the whole region you can imagine with
this amount of money is in the hands of
Islamist extremist llama groups this is
a very big problem you absolutely right
but you know there was a moment a couple
of months ago when you could really see
that the militant the violent Islamist
groups like insertion area and the let's
say Muslim
muslim brother affiliated groups were
disagreeing they were kind of splitting
there was a lot of you know California
among the Islamist groups in Libya then
halifa hafta arrived this you know
dubious officer self-declared head of
the new Libyan army who took revenge who
launched Operation Karama and you know
he said like I will stop the killing of
Libyan army officers he got again a lot
of sympathy he kind of people believed
in an Egyptian military solution in
Libya like an Egyptian style solution
but even then everybody be on the run he
but yeah but everybody was frustrated
because of a gauzy as well and what
happened there's like you know due to
these the cuff tears operations the
Islamists reunited and you know you
could see the Grand Mufti of Libya
whatever important that person is but he
could you could hear him declare that
the marsala Sharia would die as martyrs
on the battlefield whereas the seculars
who side with half dog would die as
infidels this is something and and the
international community was I was very
intrigued because I thought after might
be an option might be a player that
would get the support of you know the
Americans the British all those that
believe in you know stability as a
prerogative but in fact what happened is
you know it made the situation worse 70
are we under estimating the conflict in
Libya in the international community in
the Western world yes if we allow a
disintegration of Libya we will create
sanctuaries for radical Islam and which
we will also enjoy the possibility of
having oil and gas rents so this is
something that cannot happen and i think
that the central state must gain back
control of the territory one last word
Malik what gives you hope although
everything that's been said I have hope
in the Libyan people which which where
they have the revolution in 2011 and I
hope everything is will be correct well
let's hope let's hope that Libya will
get on the right track thank you for a
very enlightening discussion about Libya
thank you out there for tuning in and
looking forward to seeing you again next
week for a new edition of quadriga